Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to let's go
to Nick from Florida. Nick, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hello. Sorry to the. But I just
wanted to ask. I care about the environment,
and there's this one thing where people are buying
like exotic pets down here, and I wanted to get
like a piece of legislation or legislation to make
it so that it's not as common or is like people
are discouraged in doing that without getting
like a license. Is there anything I can do?
I want to get a start in doing beautiful.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Start with your local
officials. So I would I would start with I
mean, I don't know if you can if it would,
that has to be I don't know enough about exotic
pet laws to know they're probably state level,
but maybe some of this stuff is municipality.
I would start with mayor, city councilors,
state rep, state senator, governor's office.
Right to all of them and and see if anybody is
willing to work with you on that. But that's
exactly I mean, you have a specific idea.
This is what our legislators are supposed
to be there for. Reach out to all of them
directly and see who will listen to you.
Speaker 4: OK, one more thing. You're a godsend.
Whatever you answer of decirte easily extreme's.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK. Well I will, I will try to. Do
you mean interrupt by going by
Speaker 4: on my thing. On.
Oh by hopping on. Oh yeah.
Speaker 1: Well I'll try to keep
doing it then. Thank you. All right, very good.
Yeah, those exotic pets, that's bad news, folks,
that's really, really bad news